et si on est équilibré l'agriculture a
des intérêts offensifs et défensifs
elle a notamment sur le vin et sur les
produits laitiers plutôt des intérêts
offensifs mais on a des intérêts très
défensifs notamment sur l'élevage et la
viande bovine et que vu sa situation il
faut faire les ovins aussi il faut faire
des choix je le dis tout le monde parle
le Mercosur la semaine dernière
l'Australie a obtenu un quota
d'importation de viande de 24000 tonnes
en franchise de doigts de douane en
Europe donc je veux dire que en même
temps que le rapport sortait tout tout
ça voilà bon il faut qu'à un moment on
soit cohérent je voudrais vous donner
les chiffres je ne renonce pas à aucun
moment au plan au Plan National
Nutrition Santé qui est un bien public
sur lequel il faut qu'on soit
collectivement vigilant et je n'ignore
pas les problèmes d'obésité ou
malnutrition je dis simplement
qu'on ne peut pas d'un côté nous
expliquer qu'il faudrait réduire la
consommation mieux manger et réduire le
nombre de têtes de bétails et dans le
même temps voir des importations qui ne
cessent d'augmenter moi je vous donne la
réalité des chiffres la réalité des
chiffres c'est que nous consommons en
France environ 1,5 millions de tonnes de
viande bovine ce chiffre est
relativement stable je parle de viande
bovine je ne parle pas de la totalité
des viandes ce chiffre est relativement
stable il varie de quelques pourcents
c'est à dire que ça n'est pas
significatif il a tendance à baisser
père capita mais le volume total et le
même
en revanche ce qui augmente beaucoup
c'est les importations on est on a passé
le stade des 400.000 tonnes importés
donc on est à 25% d'importation Novion
bobines et là je vous le dis 25% c'est
avec aussi ce qu'on exporte on fait un
petit peu de viande sur l'Italie les
broutards un peu sur l'Algérie soldes
c'est 25%. et ça ne cesse d'augmenter
donc expliquer qu'on va pouvoir qu'il
faudrait pardonner moi réduire sa
consommation de viande certainement pour
ceux qui en consomment trop de l'autre
réduire chez tel français alors qu'on ne
cesse dans n'importe plus et que la
consommation globale ne change pas c'est
pardonnez-moi inacceptable pour le
président de la FNSEA et